thank you all right so tonight we're
gonna be talking about parsing
expression grammars and we're gonna be
making your own pairing language so ya
up to this point you know HTML CSS and
JavaScript have collectively functioned
as you know the lingua franca of the web
it's like if you want to build something
that's connecting people you're probably
using HTML CSS and JavaScript backed by
some back-end language maybe even
JavaScript some of the largest apps in
the world you know are built using these
three languages in addition to some but
back in language like you know Facebook
PayPal YouTube but we're talking about
apps that have completely revolutionized
industries and experiences so we should
be really proud right
yeah sort of it turns out that um in the
beginning while these languages were
being designed they were designed with
usability and productivity shortcomings
none of their creators anticipated and
that largely has to do with you know us
as developers taking these programming
languages outside of the boundaries of
what they were designed to do you know
these languages were primarily designed
to build content based sites with like
bits of insert interactivity
versus like you know the interaction
heavy web sites that we use now like
Facebook Twitter vine so yeah an example
of an older site that was perfect for
this was the Space Jam site and here we
have Junior Jam portion the web site and
we have our one bit in the corner that
actually isn't scripted when it's just a
gift like it's just pretty pretty happy
there right so unfortunately the
approachability and egalitarian Haysom
envisioned by Tim berners-lee and his
peers isn't really suitable for building
large scale applications and what I mean
by that is like you know for example not
being able something as simple as being
able to nest things of them CSS can
become a pain when you're you know
trying to get one work done quickly um
but we managed to build these pretty
complicated apps with these tools for
quite some time and eventually you know
people got fed up I guess as developers
so then came the source-to-source
compiler x' you know like your
CoffeeScript your Lester sass and you
know a number of others and these
languages make things like substantially
easier far more palatable for seasoned
engineers and newcomers by handling like
you know language blemishes like you
know odd behaviors in JavaScript or like
da Chios like I mentioned earlier not
being able to nest things in CSS so in
the next slide I have some code that
demonstrates that plenty of you in the
audience have probably already seen this
but for example similarly the same
applies for another one of these
languages CoffeeScript you know we're
all familiar with this we know beaten
the stuff into the ground right and
newer versions of HTML CSS and
JavaScript are getting like your early
features that you know stem of their own
and they're also incorporating some of
the great things that were thought of in
these scripting languages but you know
we're not here to discuss the viability
of you know the sub languages going
forward
we're here to write around and the way
we're going to do that is using peg KS
and PEG yes of course is a parser
generator
so what's a parser generator a parser
generator is a program capable of
reading in a specification and
generating another program to reprogram
code that adheres the rules in the
specification right just whoa morpheus
so we're going to be looking at a parser
generator
you know library as I mentioned before
call Peggy Jas and there are a number of
others in particular one called Jason
which is uses a different syntax but
today I'm primary we've been focusing on
Peggy yes and we're gonna start by
looking at language I built called
classy script and it's not very
complicated in fact it's sort of a
contrived example of showing you how
you'd go about building your own
language and it's the learning tool to
demonstrate how traditional classes
translate to JavaScript and when I say
change there's traditional classes I
mean like you know C++ style classes
with access specifiers like your public
and private and virtual things like that
so we have our expected input if you've
ever programmed people so notice that
this doesn't exactly here there's no
like the class dog and it has two XFX
fire sections one public and one private
and in this next example I know this is
probably gonna elicit some odd feelings
amongst people but it's just a very
contrived example we're gonna see the
expected output for a Java Script and
that's gonna be this object so the this
num T would represent you know our
public member and then our happiness
will be our private one so yeah let's
just get this going here we're gonna go
to the peg JSI they have a live
and if I hadn't had that kernel panic
okay so this is the site it has very
excellent documentation well okay well
just disappear oh wow this is this is
fun
all right are you awesome so it's a bit
it's a tad large but when you go to the
online version tab there the the live
editor is already populated with a
generator a parser generator and grammar
so this particular grammar is a classic
calculator much like you'd see in
spotlight so it does like you know math
and we're just going to run through how
the so we start with an expression that
is defined as a primary flanked by this
the asterisk standing in this you know
the multiplication operator or primary
and a primary just an integer integer I
know this grammar isn't the best to
start with so I'm just going to like get
this out of there and I think it'll be a
little bit clearer what's going on when
we start building classy script so
just give me one
okay
okay I'm just going to take this out of
here
we're gonna drop that in here okay so we
are already getting an error because
this output is not supported by our
parser and you have the wrong comment up
here so cool so this one is a bit
clearer I think because it's less
abstract than the mathematical example
but we're going to start with a class
definition and the class definition is
defined as starting with the beginning
of the word class separated by
whitespace following an identifier which
look just before this comment here are
the letters as you'd like which is sort
of a bug in this and I'll show you that
just now now following that we have
white space and an open curly brace then
a bit more white space wow this is
actually not the version I was hoping to
show yeah this is like not even Wow okay
so that should yield us an output
oh wow this is a
sorry just give me one second yeah
so the class has to be bookended by oh I
don't know there's a book on this page
that resizes this entry box but you saw
we were able to turn this into a
JavaScript function which is a
first-class object I think my example
got screwed up so I will not be able to
show you the remainder of this language
but that I did write read another one
thankfully and that one is fully
functional so those are just some of the
concepts that go into crafting your own
language unfortunately this one didn't
turn out as I would have liked so we're
just gonna go back here and I know you
guys must be wondering at this point you
know there must be a more interesting
application for using this parser
generator than you know building boring
trance powers of like you know classes
woman like stealer and I thought there
was so I decided to write what I call
uniform and it's still in its beginning
stages but it uses the peg parser is
huge and rates a JSON output from input
that looks less like a program and more
like a tweet so the expen expected input
in that scenario would be you know the @
symbol followed by a category name then
a property name followed by its value
and then another property name followed
by its value and and so on and so forth
so theoretically you know you might be
able to abolish a form altogether and
sort of say you know when the user gets
to your forum it's like well these are
the properties and all you have to do is
enter the values and it's debatable
whether or not that's more usable than
the form but I was just sort of like you
know interested in whether or not it
would be viable and that's what the
output the expected output would be
so a little demo
and
so here we have our input box and it's
not made a parent here but by changing
the category name which is bookended by
the app symbol the color changes so
you'd think oh well I want to create a
housing listing let's say we're on a
classified advertising website then we
say we tell the user ok one of the
properties is rooms and this one has
three and you know the rent is say yeah
that's a deal right well where are we
like it's not existent so yeah this is
the sort of thing I thought would be
kind of interesting and it was very easy
to build this sort of interaction using
a peg parser and I'm going to show you
guys what the grammar looks like so you
turn gray
yeah this is okay
all right so as before in this scenario
instead of saying class the definition
we're beginning with an expression and
an expression consists of as many
categories as you'd like which is
denoted by that asterisk followed by as
many properties as you'd like and I mean
this is all very self-explanatory if you
look at it just sort of like category is
you know whitespace followed by yak
symbol followed by a word which is
defined that is no justifying and more
white space and a property similarly
it's white space followed by you know
the hash and a word with more white
space and then a phrase which is defined
well an alphanumeric rather which is
like me a through Z or you know so if
you wanted one of those values to say be
a word I don't know if this is gonna
crash you could say to the server so
yeah that's the uniform that's what's
that right now and I think I've lost my
so yeah here are a few resources there's
a peg de s documentation side if you if
you guys are interested in creating your
own languages
there's the Wikipedia page that explains
what parsing expression grammars are
it's not like reading you may fall
asleep um and yeah there's also a course
on creating your own programming
language on Nathan's University in fact
it's the only course on that site but
it's very good and you have to write you
have to pass so you're gonna test for
each implementation we were language
detail and it's very solid so yeah
that's that's about it um do you guys
have any questions yeah
yes interesting that you mentioned that
you can certainly do that and wow this
is a okay so in the documentation here
this is the beginning of a grammar at
the very top there is a function
definition so theoretically if you want
it to like pull from somewhere else some
arbitrary data and have it be part of
you know your grammar you could do so
and then call it in your yeah well this
is the output so when it when the parser
encounters a string of numbers you can
so for example we have integer here
anything to finance a primary that gets
detected is going to be run through the
integer function so it's gonna so for
example if we were multiplying something
say oh hey you know I primary that
consists of an integer and an integer
consists of a string of numbers that
must be at least like one and it's gonna
pass that into the function that you
find at the top and do whatever you
you'd like to do in there
so did I answer you were
oh okay I see what you're saying yeah um
yeah you can do that in the grammar
itself but that may end up becoming a
little bit lengthy yeah and you could
also I mean I'd imagine like you know
writing a function that returned an
array of you know all of the words that
we're keywords in the language and then
you know sort of checking that against
whatever was coming in I don't know what
implementation you'd want to go about
using but you could certainly do that
with this parser generator ya know this
particular this was born out of personal
project that I was doing and I was
interested in testing out a user
interface thing but the this parser
generator is very powerful so for
example like if you wanted to parse an
incoming CSV for some really boring you
know business application that and you
you know you had a note app and you're
like oh I want to be able to do that and
I want to do it fast fluidly you can
very easily you know npm install peg j s
write your parser and then when that
boring CSV comes and every morning it's
like oh well that's pretty easy to do
because I've defined this grammar for
doing so I think maybe for this audience
that might have been a bit more useful
but I thought you know the
I example it was a bit more playful and
fun but it's certainly a robust enough
tool that if you needed to use it for
something boring and work-related to
actually get work done you could and I'd
encourage you to check out the
documentation to check it out and play
around with some boring real-world stuff
yeah I don't know yeah so yeah is anyone
have any other